how's your jaw that went bright after
the surgery yes i don't know yeah yeah
it's almost exactly a year ago that
brian wright had his lower jaw replaced
with bone taken from his leg surgery
needed because he had a tumor in his
mouth
he's recovered well but head and neck
cancer has a high chance of returning so
he's part of a trial to test a vaccine
made from his own tumor a personal jab
that should put his immune system on
watch for the first sign of a relapse he
wasn't sure at first
if you've got cancer in your throat like
well throwing up
and they're gonna inject me again with
that country
it just sounds oh no you're not
but when you talk to people who neck the
explain
walk through the counter back it'll stop
it coming to make the vaccine cancer
cells are first removed from an
individual patient dna mutations unique
to the tumor are identified and then cut
and pasted into a harmless virus
when the virus is injected into the body
it trains the immune system to target
cancer cells hopefully destroying them
before they even form a lump
if we can train the immune system to
pick those cancer cells that would
otherwise lead to a relapse
at a time when we can't even see them
then the chances of long-term survival
for our patient is much higher i'm quite
excited about this but i think the the
all the data pointing in the right
direction
early results show all eight patients to
receive the vaccine so far have remained
well after several months but two of
another eight who weren't given the jab
have relapsed
the vaccine they're using here is
experimental but the technology that
lies behind it proved itself during the
pandemic astrazeneca's kovid jab was
made in a very similar way and what
about the mrna technique that lay behind
the moderna and fisa vaccines well it's
being used elsewhere with very hopeful
results against pancreatic cancer
scientists in oxford developed the
astrazeneca jab and are now working on a
vaccine to treat prostate cancer they're
applying what they learned with covid
the pandemic has helped and accelerated
the development of a whole range of new
vaccines
we learned about their safety in
billions of people whereas previously it
had been in thousands that's very
helpful safety data to have
and it means that there will be a lot
more investment now in fields like
cancer where we desperately need better
therapies
brian has a dose of his vaccine every
three weeks but he feels so good that
right now he's off for a pint
thomas more sky news in liverpool